what is a food-stamp first thing is
these days they're not actually stamps
but government debit cards they're given
to people with low income to buy an
average of a hundred and twenty-five
dollars worth of food per month the
programs called snap and you can buy
these kind of foods you can't however
buy items like these to qualify you have
to earn less than one thousand two
hundred sixty-five dollars a month or
two thousand five hundred eighty four
dollars for a family of four the
overwhelming majority of people on food
stamps who can work do and one out of
every five American children depends on
the program for food
you